para aquellas personas que decidieron
pasar sus vacaciones en españa volver a
francia es más complicado que nunca
desde el 17 de julio los ciudadanos
franceses que aún no se han vacunado
necesitarán una prueba pcr tomada 24
horas antes del vuelo en vez de las 72
horas establecidas anteriormente para
regresar a francia me asusté cuando oí
las noticias
rápidamente abre internet para agendar
una prueba antes de aquí es muy molesto
porque ahora tenemos que encontrar un
centro de toma de pruebas investigar y
eso tomará bastante tiempo de nuestras
vacaciones los pasajeros franceses que
viajan de regreso desde portugal se
enfrentan a medidas similares las
restricciones impuestas por los países
continúan evolucionando
para viajar italia por ejemplo los
pasajeros deben tener una pc r tomada 48
horas antes del vuelo o deben estar
completamente vacunados en malta además
de un test con negativo los viajeros aún
tienen que hacer una cuarentena de dos
semanas después de su ingreso al país
las nuevas fricciones están causando
largas filas en los aeropuertos tiene un
certificado de viaje una prueba de kobe
de 72 horas toma mucho más tiempo
chequear nuestro equipaje ya nosotros
mismos esto además de todas las otras
verificaciones de verificación como
respuesta a los largos tiempos de espera
varias aerolíneas como coches y iphones
que están permitiendo que los pasajeros
registren sus certificados de salud
antes del viaje en este paso a bordo
puedes ver el ready to fly lo que
significa que ya verificamos los
documentos de salud y ya puede abordar
directamente porque está listo para el
viaje por ahora este nuevo sistema está
sólo disponible para aquellos viajeros
que se dirijan a córcega oa territorios
franceses de ultramar este verano efe
msh quiere implementar el mecanismo
ready to fly para todos sus destinos